BRANDON KVARDE: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to "CE Chat,"
hosted by Cloud OnAir--
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Brandon Kvarde.
I'm a Cloud customer
engineer at Google.
And joining me today
is Morgan McLean,
who is a product manager
here at Google, as well.
Today, we're going to be
talking about OpenCensus.
Just a quick reminder
for everybody
who's watching the stream live--
you can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on standby
to answer those questions
for you.
So let's go ahead
and get started.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Hi, everyone.
So as Brandon mentioned,
my name is Morgan McLean.
I'm the product manager
for OpenCensus, which is
what we're talking about today.
I'm also the product manager
for our Stackdriver APM
line, which includes Stackdriver
Trace, Debugger, and Profiler.
So let's get started,
and dive into OpenCensus.
BRANDON KVARDE: Let's do it.
MORGAN MCLEAN: So for
those who don't know,
OpenCensus is a set of
telemetry collection libraries.
We'll get into what exactly
that means in a minute.
But to start, I just want to
talk about the journey of how
we arrived at this.
So inside of Google,
we use technologies
like distributed tracing,
and application metrics,
and distributed metrics.
And one of the challenges
that we perceived at Google
a number of years ago was
actually collecting telemetry
from our applications.
So in order to capture things
like a distributed trace, which
tracks a request as it
propagates across services,
you have to have a
bunch of integrations
into all of the
network interactions
that you have on your system.
And this is difficult.
So we created a
project called Census.
OpenCensus is effectively
an externalization of this.
And this is part of a
longer-term trend at Google.
If you look at
Kubernetes, for example,
it's effectively
an externalization
of Borg, which is the
container management system.
gRPC is an externalization
of something internal
called Stubby, which does RPCs.
OpenCensus is just another
part of that same story.
And so we're hoping to share
the same benefits that we've
received at Google, from
Census, with our customers
and with the world
through OpenCensus.
So let's dive into your
traditional application
as they were developed
a few years ago.
So most things were
built as a monolith.
This can be anything
from a client application
on a phone, or even basic
web services back in the day
where you would go and build
a single large, self-contained
application.
These are fairly easy to get
observability and telemetry
into.
This has been perfected
over a number of years.
Where if you want to understand
how the parts of your app
interact with each other,
you can do things like
collect a stack trace
from an exception
or from a break point.
And testing and staging, or
non-production environments,
is also fairly
straightforward with
these monolithic applications.
There's a lot of
good solutions there.
But as most of our viewers
are more than aware,
everyone's been shifting
to microservices
over the last few years.
And this is for good reasons.
Microservices are much
easier to operate at scale.
They're much more
maintainable when
you have to build a
larger application that
handles hundreds,
thousands, tens of thousands
of requests per second.
And so microservices are
generally really good
and really powerful
architecture.
But one of the challenges
of microservices
is actually being able to manage
them and gain observability
into what's happening.
So a lot of those lessons
or those techniques
that we had in the past where
we try and capture a trace,
like a stack trace
of our application,
are no longer really applicable.
If we have the application
that you see here with services
A, B, and C, and you
want to understand
for a particular request or a
particular customer interaction
how those services interact,
capturing a stack trace
from service C
isn't that valuable
because you don't know what
happened in the client or A
and B. And so techniques
like distributed tracing
had to be invented for that.
Distributed tracing
was certainly
popularized by Google.
We published a paper
back in, I think,
2010 about the Dapper
tracing system that
exists inside of a company.
And what it allows you to do is
understand how these requests
flow across systems.
So for example, if you have
some kind of interaction
you're curious
about in service C,
you can capture a single
customer request that
stems from your client app.
This goes to service A,
does some processing there.
Goes to service B, does
some processing there.
It maybe calls up to service
C in database and parallel.
And the distributed
trace will show
you that across all
of these applications.
BRANDON KVARDE: Awesome.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Another
really useful thing
that's difficult to do
is distributed metrics.
So for a monolith, all
we would need to do
is capture things like latency
metrics for the entire app.
And that's relatively
straightforward.
But in a microservices
world, we actually
want to capture, for
example, latency metrics
from each individual service.
It's not enough to
understand that one
of the endpoints
exposed by service A
is slow in this example.
We also want to understand which
interactions on service B and C
are slow--
and so not just understanding
that B and C themselves
are slow, but of the actual
end points exposed by B and C,
we want to see latency and
statistics about the RPCs.
And so there's a lot
of complexity here.
To get this kind
of instrumentation
out of your app, you
have to go and build it.
So this involves
getting integrations.
And if you want
it automatically,
it involves getting integrations
into various web frameworks,
RPC frameworks, storage clients,
and other client libraries
that your application uses.
And this is annoying
and difficult.
And this is one of the reasons
that things like distributed
tracing historically haven't
been that popular in smaller
companies.
It's just too
expensive to get going.
And so with OpenCensus,
we're making
this a lot more accessible.
So with OpenCensus, we give
you automatic instrumentation.
We give you APIs and
exporters to handle your data.
And I'll dive into what
these mean in a minute.
But at its core,
OpenCensus is a set
of language-specific
instrumentation libraries.
So we have libraries
for Java, Node.js.
We're building one for .Net.
We also have Go, C++,
Python, Ruby, and PHP.
And so we have a lot of coverage
across all of these languages.
And we have libraries
that you just
link to your application
to get the observability
and insight into your app.
Each of these libraries, once
linked to your application,
will automatically collect
traces and RPC-related metrics
from your application.
So for example, we have
integrations for various HTTP
clients, for gRPC, for
things like MongoDB
where, as a
developer, once you've
linked the library to your
app, you do no additional work.
We automatically will
capture traces and propagate
contexts and things like that.
For those who aren't
aware, just when I
say context propagation,
what that means is,
to capture that request
that goes from A to B
to C into the database, you need
to pass some kind of identifier
or something so that you
can actually correlate
all of those requests later.
The next thing that
OpenCensus provides is APIs.
So not only do we automatically
collect a lot of information
from your application,
we also let you manually
interact with that.
So with the APIs,
you can do things
like define a custom
stat or custom metric
and send that to your back end.
You can manually add spans or
components to your traces--
things that weren't
automatically captured,
or long-running
processes that you
want to capture in as
a part of the trace.
And you can add custom
metadata or custom tags
to both of these.
You can also configure
things with the APIs.
So traces that I mentioned
before, distributed traces,
we don't capture every request.
Generally, with most
tracing systems,
there's something
called sampling
where, roughly, on
average, 1% of the requests
are actually traced.
This is to reduce costs
and reduce the performance
impact of tracing.
The APIs in OpenCensus allow
you to configure this manually.
Finally, another key part
of OpenCensus is exporters.
So rather than just sending
data back to Stackdriver or back
to a particular
back end, OpenCensus
sends data to your
back end of choice.
This is why OpenCensus is
not just a Google project.
We're actually participating
with a number of vendors,
though we were certainly
the initiators of it.
So with OpenCensus,
you can send data
back to Zipkin or
Prometheus, which
are the main open-source
back ends that we target.
So all features for OpenCensus
have to work in Prometheus.
You can also send data back
to Stackdriver, of course.
But you can send
your telemetry back
to Datadog, SolarWinds, Jaeger,
and a number of other back
ends for processing.
BRANDON KVARDE: Could
you send them to multiple
at the same time?
MORGAN MCLEAN: You can.
And we'll go into
that in a minute--
so the benefits of that.
But you can.
A really common use
case for OpenCensus
is sending data to Zipkin
for tracing and Prometheus
for stats.
Right?
And so you can send stats to one
back end and traces to another.
You can also just send that to
multiple even of the same type.
BRANDON KVARDE: Awesome.
MORGAN MCLEAN: We'll go
into that in a minute.
But yeah, that's
a good question.
It's a really powerful feature.
So as I mentioned before,
we have really great support
for Java, C++, and Go.
OpenCensus has already
had tracing support--
not stat support,
but tracing support
for Ruby, Python,
and PHP, though we're
adding stats to those now.
I think stats was just
added to Python last week.
So I should have
updated this deck.
And finally, we have full
support under development
for Node.js and .Net.
The Node.js client also
just went into to alpha.
So you can go use it, it's
just in a very early state.
Of course, OpenCensus has
a ton of integrations.
There's far too many to
list, but we effectively
cover all HTTP,
gRPC, SQL clients,
storage clients like MongoDB,
and various web frameworks.
The web framework
integrations are there
to get you automatic
context propagation,
so you don't have to manually
correlate an incoming request
with an outgoing one in
order to get a trace.
It sounds trivial.
That's actually a really
powerful feature of OpenCensus,
is just removing that
work that you have to do.
Finally, we have many exporters.
So of course, our native
open-source exporters
are for Zipkin and Prometheus.
But we also support Jaeger,
SignalFx, Datadog, SolarWinds,
Instana, Amazon X-Ray, and
of course, Stackdriver.
And as you asked, you can
use multiple of these.
You can mix and match
and use different ones
at the same time,
which is really nice.
So we're going to do
a demo of OpenCensus.
I'm going to show you both the
telemetry that we've captured
and how easy it was
to get configured.
The demo app for this is going
to be Hipster Shop, which
I'll show you in a minute.
If you tuned into
Next, basically any
of the presentations at
Next, they used Hipster Shop.
It's a new demo app that
we've created for GCP.
And it's an e-commerce
system that's
deployed across a number
of different microservices
and Kubernetes.
So it's got a front
end written in Go,
and then it has several back
end services written in Python,
Node.js, Go, and .Net Core.
As I mentioned before, it's
all running on Kubernetes.
And it uses a combination
of HTTP and gRPC
to communicate between
these services.
So the front end will talk
to web browsers in HTTP,
obviously, but the service
interactions inside
of the application are
both in HTTP and gRPC.
And so this is a great
testbed for OpenCensus,
because it has to do with
things like propagate context
and capture traces across those
different RPC mechanisms, which
is traditionally not that easy.
It also uses various
GCP client libraries,
and it can track
requests across those.
This particular
demonstration of Hipster Shop
doesn't use an
external database.
But rest assured, we do support
basically all SQL clients
and things like MongoDB
and other storage clients.
So let's hop to the demo.
So this is the Hipster Shop app.
Again, if you watched
GCP Next at all,
you're probably intimately
familiar with it.
This is the slow
version of Hipster Shop
that we used in
one of the keynotes
when we used the Stackdriver
APM tools to diagnose it.
We're using it for this
demonstration of OpenCensus
because, as a part
of being slow,
it generates really nice
telemetry for us to inspect.
So to start, we're
going to look at traces.
So this is Stackdriver trace.
Again, with OpenCensus, you
can use any tracing back end,
like Zipkin or others.
And while we're using
Stackdriver for this demo,
it's just because that's
what I'm most familiar with.
So what you can see here
are the various requests
that were captured
from the application.
And all of our telemetry
in the app uses OpenCensus.
And we can click
between a few of these.
And so when we look
at one of these--
so this is a request that a
web browser made to the cart
service--
we can see how that
request was handled
across all of these services.
And so if you weren't already
aware of what distributed
tracing is, and my description
earlier wasn't visual enough,
this should really show
you the power of it.
So we can see from here that
the request comes into cart,
but then it has
child requests that
go to the currency service,
to the recommendation
service, and then several times
to the product catalog service.
And then later on, again, it
hops to the currency service.
So with this distributed
trace, we learn a few things.
First, we understand just
a few of the services
and how they interact.
For example, we know that the
cart service calls the currency
service directly.
And if we weren't developers
of this application,
we didn't have intimate
knowledge of how it works,
the trace is a really
powerful way for us
to understand
those interactions.
Without distributed tracing,
you effectively can't see those.
And the next thing
we can understand
is how these are chained.
So we can see that the cart
calls the product catalog
service, which then the
request goes back to the cart,
and then it calls the product
catalog service again.
And then it calls the
products catalog service
again, and so on.
And so if we're trying to
optimize their application,
this is probably something
we would want to fix.
This seems really
inefficient when
we're reading a single piece
of information from the cart.
We might expect, maybe, the
cart has a few items in it,
but it seems odd that
these calls aren't batched,
or at least done in parallel.
And so from just glancing
at this distributed trace,
we've seen a whole
bunch of ways we can
improve the latency of our app.
And of course, this should
be a priority for us.
This request to the cart
took about eight seconds
to process, which is awful
for an e-commerce system.
BRANDON KVARDE: So Morgan,
what we're looking at here
is actually a trace from a
bunch of different microservices
written in different languages.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
That's correct, yeah.
And so, again, this is part
of the power of OpenCensus
is the support of
all these languages.
BRANDON KVARDE: Awesome.
MORGAN MCLEAN: That's
not necessarily something
you'd get with all
third-party vendors.
Some have really great
support, some only focus
on a few languages.
But with OpenCensus,
we've got coverage
across eight of the most used
languages on the web, which
is really great.
BRANDON KVARDE: Very cool.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
And again, just to
reiterate, because OpenCensus
is an open source
project-- we're
showing this in
Stackdriver trace.
If you were using Zipkin or
a Datadog's APM software,
or something else, you'd
see a very similar view.
So now I'm going to show
you how we got this.
So we have a function
that we wrote
in our code called
initTracing, just so we
could encapsulate everything.
And inside of initTracing,
you can see where we actually
registered OpenCensus.
We have one line at the
top of this app that just
imports the OpenCensus library.
What we do here is
actually, for a trace code,
we register an exporter.
And then we just turn on
OpenCensus for tracing.
And that's it.
I think there's one line down
below where we had to just make
a change to gRPC to
enable OpenCensus,
but that's a three-line change.
You've got distributed tracing.
Go ahead.
BRANDON KVARDE: So
there's no tricks here.
It's just this function,
and imports at the top.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Correct.
Correct.
Yeah, it's really,
really straightforward.
And with this, not only
are we capturing the traces
and sampling, but
we're also doing things
like propagating
context automatically.
So as a developer with
this particular app--
it's written in Go--
it's really, really simple
and straightforward.
And that's the
experience that we strive
for across all languages.
It's generally something
that we've achieved.
If you're using
something like Java
and crossing thread
boundaries, you
do need to add a
small amount of code
every time you do that
so that we can just
track how to propagate context.
But in general, as a developer,
the work required here
is very, very minimal,
which is awesome.
That's the core
value of OpenCensus.
And with that, we were
able to capture traces
across our application.
Obviously, our application
has some non-Go components.
So it's got Python.
For that, we use
OpenCensus Python.
Similar experience-- you just
import it, instantiate it.
You're done.
BRANDON KVARDE: Makes sense.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
And so it's great.
And because it's
just a library, you
can manage this entirely
through source control.
So there's no black
box agent that
needs to always update
itself or something
you need to set up on your
VM images or in Kubernetes.
You simply link this
to your source code,
make a few changes.
You can version it,
you can control it
from there, which is great.
The next thing I'm going
to show you is metrics.
So we've talked a
lot about tracing.
But OpenCensus, of
course, also does stats.
And so I'm going to show you,
first, some of the metrics
that we automatically
capture from the application.
So as I mentioned early
on in this presentation,
one of the things that's really,
really useful in microservices
is understanding the
latency of every end
point on every service.
This is not always
an easy thing to do--
unless you use OpenCensus,
in which case it is.
And so what we've got here is
a stat that's automatically
captured by OpenCensus.
This is not a stat I had to
define and code as a developer
or really do anything for.
And we're capturing the gRPC
latency for each end point.
And so you can see
here, here's a list
of endpoints for the service
that I've instrumented.
And you can see the
99th percentile latency
that's captured in Stackdriver.
You would get the
exact same experience
in Prometheus or Datadog,
or any of the other back
ends that OpenCensus supports.
Again, we're just
showing Stackdriver
because it's what I happen
to be most familiar with.
And so we can use this to
understand that the PlaceOrder
method, for example,
is relatively slow
and has a lot of variance in
its 99th percentile latency.
At the same time, the GetProduct
method on the product catalog
service is also slow, but
looks like its 99th percentile
latency is roughly
around 4 seconds.
But it has a lot less variance.
We can also see, though,
that some parts of our app
are relatively fast--
the GetQuote for the
shipping service,
or ListProducts from the
product catalog service.
And so if we're trying to track
the health of our application,
this can actually narrow
down our investigations
if there's a problem into
a particular end point--
so not just telling us
that our app is slow,
not just telling us that a
certain interaction is slow,
but a particular end point
of a particular service
is where the slowdown is.
And so this is great
for monitoring.
You can set alerts and things
like this on these metrics.
It's also great during
those investigations.
And this is not the only metric
we capture automatically.
I think we capture others like
the request size and others.
Just latency is
generally the one
that we like to
demonstrate the most.
And to capture this, if
we jump back to the code,
this is what I did up here.
So in addition to registering
OpenCensus for tracing,
I also registered it for
our default gRPC views.
So this just captures some
basic gRPC-related stats.
And I actually did the
instrumentation of this part
of the code myself.
This was my first
time writing Go, ever.
I do a fair amount of
programming in other languages,
just haven't done it
in Go much before.
And I got this and
some other work done
in about just under one hour.
And someone who doesn't even
know the language working
with adding some instrumentation
would normally take forever,
because you have to understand
what you're actually
interacting with.
For me, it was really,
really straightforward.
BRANDON KVARDE: Right.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And
so it was great.
BRANDON KVARDE: And
it's that same function
that we looked at earlier for
instantiating both the tracing
and metric function.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Correct.
Yeah.
So in the OpenCensus
parlance, we call metrics--
views is one way to
describe a metric.
And so for this, we just write
a certain export for a view,
and then just told it where to
go and subscribe to metrics.
There's certainly slightly
more work involved
in getting the view going.
You just have a few
lines of code up above
to actually go and set
things up for a custom view.
But for any of the
built-in default views,
it's really, really
straightforward.
Speaking of custom
views, that's what
I'm going to show you next.
So we also have a
custom stat that we
capture from our
application with OpenCensus.
As a developer,
there's a huge amount
of value in automatically
capturing things
like latency metrics,
but we can also
let you capture custom metrics.
These are often business
metrics or things like that.
For this e-commerce
system, what we've captured
is the number of items purchased
in a particular checkout
action.
And so this is captured
over a one-minute time
interval, and then
[AUDIO OUT] after that.
And we can see over
time, the number of items
purchased while we
run our load test.
The various numbers
of items purchased
ranges between one item and
six items per checkout action
over a minute.
And so this is
obviously not something
that you could ever
capture automatically
from your application.
Business metrics
like this always
have to be custom defined.
But OpenCensus also
makes that fairly easy.
So if we go above,
we can see here,
this is where we've
actually gone and defined
the custom view.
So while, of course,
it's a little more work
than the things that we
automatically capture--
that's the benefit of
them being automatic--
it's still very, very simple
to define and register
a custom view inside of
your application's code.
And again, the nice thing about
this being in your app's code
is that it's defined
in source control.
If you need to make changes,
version it, roll it back,
you already have
processes around that.
And so doing things like
registering a new view--
you can simply put
that in a code review,
push that out to production,
data starts showing up.
It's really powerful.
BRANDON KVARDE:
And there's nothing
you have to do on
the back end side?
MORGAN MCLEAN: That's correct.
BRANDON KVARDE: OK.
MORGAN MCLEAN: We simply started
sending this to our back end--
in this case Stackdriver,
but that could be Prometheus
or something else--
and nothing there.
It will just start picking
up this new statistic
and then rendering it to the UI.
So this is where we actually
register the new view.
We can also hop down in the code
to where we actually record it.
And so this is what you'll
have to write more often.
Right?
So you typically only need
to register something once
in a particular service.
But if you want to record
it in multiple locations,
the recording process
is really easy.
All we do is look at the
length of the order items
array in our code
and record that down
to the Items Purchased view.
It's really, really simple.
And that generates
this really nice graph
inside of Stackdriver, or
whatever monitoring solution
we're using.
And so with
OpenCensus, we've taken
something that historically is
very difficult-- automatically
capturing traces, propagating
context, attaching metadata
to those traces, in
addition to all the stuff
on the metric side--
and we've made
it really simple,
and straightforward,
and manageable,
through source control.
That's why we're so
excited about the project.
That's why we're talking
about it here today.
So with that, let's hop
back to our presentation
and finish things up.
So there are also some really
cool features in OpenCensus
that I didn't show you today.
One of those is Z-pages.
So Z-pages are these
health or status pages
that you can optionally
host from the OpenCensus
clients themselves.
What they show you
is the firehose view
of stats and RPC metadata.
This is information that's not
typically sent to a back end.
If you think of stats
sent to a back end,
they're usually aggregated over
a minute or some other time
period to save space and
reduce network congestion.
And traces, as I mentioned
before, are typically sampled.
Most companies sample
at a roughly 1% rate.
So the Z-pages show
you the information
that's not always sent to
your back end for analysis.
This is useful if
you think there's
an issue with a
particular service
or a particular
instance of a service,
but it's not being
captured by your back end.
You can jump into the Z-page.
You can see everything that's
running through that system
and catch any patterns.
We're also building some
interaction mechanisms
between Z-pages and the
OpenCensus clients where
you can do things like
change the sampling strategy
inside of a Z-page without
having to redeploy your app.
We use these at
Google extensively.
We're actually really
excited to see how people
outside of Google use them.
The next thing we have is
the W3C trace-context format.
So about two years ago, we
kicked off a small project
between Google and
some Zipkin developers
to define a common trace
context propagation format.
That's since grown to involve
a number of other big companies
like Microsoft,
Dynatrace, and others.
Context propagation,
as I mentioned before,
is what allows you to actually
get traces across services.
It's typically a
common ID that's
used to link when service A
talks to service B, B to C, C
to D, and so on.
That context will be the same.
And that's how, later
on, you can process
those to build a single trace.
The challenge today is
that vendors typically
use their own context
propagation formats.
So for Stackdriver,
historically, we
had an HTTP header called, I
think, X Google Cloud Trace.
For Zipkin, they have
various HTTP headers
that are known as the
B3 headers, and so on.
And so there are
a lot of benefits
to having vendors align on
a common context propagation
format.
One of those is that if you have
multiple vendors participating
in a trace-- let's say you have
different companies and they
want to trace a
single interaction,
or different parts of a company
use different back ends--
you want those to be
able to communicate.
The second is black box tracing.
So if you have something
like a network load balancer
inside of your application
that strips headers from HTTP
requests, you'll break a trace.
With a common context
propagation format or even
just a common header, that
won't happen, because now we
can work with those vendors.
And certainly, big names like
Google, Microsoft, Dynatrace,
and others, we
can achieve this--
where we can tell those
vendors of load balancers
and other things to stop
stripping headers or at least
stop stripping this
particular header
so that the trace will continue.
As we discussed before,
another really cool feature
of OpenCensus is
multi-exporter support.
So you can choose multiple
exporters at once.
This is useful in
situations where
you have different parts
of your organization using
different back ends.
Let's say, maybe,
you use a combination
of Zipkin and Prometheus where
you have metrics sent to one,
stats to the other-- or,
sorry, traces to the other.
And so we can handle that.
Or if you have--
let's say you're using
Zipkin in part of the company
and Solarwinds in another part,
or SignalFx in another part.
With OpenCensus, you can
support all those back ends.
So you don't have to build the
instrumentation three times,
which is awesome.
Secondly, you can send all
of the data to all back ends.
So if one team wants
to use one back end,
and another team
wants to use another,
you could support
that with OpenCensus
with very little work.
And so the multi-exporter
support is great.
It lets you achieve scenarios
that were really never possible
before without an
extreme amount of work.
And it also removes
a lot of stickiness
where, if you do want
to change vendors,
you can do it with just
changing one line of code,
which is great.
BRANDON KVARDE: Are
there any differences
in what you can send to
the different exporters
and back ends?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
The nice thing in this
industry, at least,
is that generally, most vendors
have similar notions of what
a metric is or what a trace is.
And so generally, if you choose
one vendor versus another,
basically everything is
going to show up either way.
BRANDON KVARDE: Cool.
MORGAN MCLEAN: And so
in theory, I guess,
you could have some vendors
supporting features that others
don't.
But most of them all support
the same feature set.
And for the OpenCensus
open source project,
we've been very adamant that
all features need to support
Zipkin and Prometheus.
So we're not going to add any
vendor-specific special sauce.
So there's not going to be
any special, Stackdriver-only
features in OpenCensus.
That would be really
bad for the project.
Everything has to support
our sanctioned open source
back end.
So now, I'm going to talk
about some of the new features
we're developing for
OpenCensus going forward.
Everything that I've described
thus far is for the project
as it exists today.
And so we've already come a long
way and had a lot of success,
but we're doing a lot of work
over the upcoming quarters
and years.
The first is really simple.
We're just expanding our
list of integrations--
so getting support for more
client libraries, more storage
clients, and so on.
Fairly straightforward.
The next is this thing called
the OpenCensus collector
service.
So today, OpenCensus, just
like the instrumentation
for various other vendors, sends
data directly to a back end.
So in that example we had
of service A, service B,
service C, they send data
directly to Stackdriver,
in the demo that we did.
The collector service will
be an optional component
that you can put in between
that collects all the traces
and metrics from
your application
and then reroutes them to
your back ends of choice.
It makes exporter
configuration simpler.
You only have to do
it on the service,
instead of on each client.
It also enables things
like smarter sampling.
So instead of randomly
sampling 1% of traces,
you could sample after
the fact and capture
traces that have high
latency, for example,
or traces with
associated errors,
or some other interesting
characteristics, which is
an incredibly powerful feature.
That makes tracing
dramatically more effective.
The other thing it will
enable, longer-term,
is client app support--
so support for clients
for iOS, Android, Windows,
front-end web, and so on--
where you'll have these
clients send telemetry
to the OpenCensus service
hosted within your application,
which then forwards
the data back
to your back end of choice.
And so that allows you to get
traces to have full and end
view, all the way
from a front-end web
app to your application
storage layer.
And so you can see the actual
client-perceived latency,
rather than just your
back end latencies.
It's really, really great.
Next, we're going to expand
to more telemetry types.
So we've been talking
about this for a while,
but we think we want to
capture things like logs
and exceptions, maybe one
day things like profiles,
but basically more and
more types of telemetry
from client applications.
OpenCensus is not
going to be limited
to just metrics and traces.
That is certainly not
a goal of the project.
We want to capture
as much as we can
and send it wherever you want.
And finally, we want to
keep growing the tent
to expand new partners.
So we announced at O'Reilly
Velocity a month or two ago
that Microsoft has
joined OpenCensus.
And they're doing the lion's
share of development for .Net.
They're also making some
pretty sizable contributions
for Python and,
I think, Node.js.
And so we're really
excited about that.
SignalFx has also made and will
be making some contributions.
And Pivotal, in particular, is
going to be working a lot with
Microsoft on the
.Net distribution.
And so we're really
excited to have
them making big, heavyweight
contributions to the project.
There are, of course,
also exporters
supported that
have been developed
by third-party companies.
So Datadog has
their own exporter,
SolarWinds has
and Instana has
their own exporter.
Finally, the community
has created exporters
for a number of other back ends.
So for example, we can
send traces to AWS X-Ray--
someone in the community
contributed that--
similarly, for Jaeger
and other back ends.
And so we're really excited
to watch the ecosystem
start to grow.
OpenCensus was
started by Google.
It's historically been an
entirely Google-led project.
We're really
excited to see where
it's going to go with these
new partners involved.
And with that, we're done the
main part of the presentation.
So I think we're going
to take questions.
We're going to go offline
for a minute or two,
and then we'll start
answering questions.
BRANDON KVARDE: Yep.
Thanks, Morgan.
And everybody on
the live stream,
stay tuned for the live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Welcome back, everyone.
We've received a number of
questions from the audience
that we're going to go
ahead and answer for you.
So the first one that
we got is, "Is there
any latency introduced
into the application
when leveraging
OpenCensus for tracing?"
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
That's A good question.
We get that question
a lot from OpenCensus
or any of the
telemetry recapture.
The answer is,
there's effectively
no measurable latency introduced
for tracing or for metrics.
We've done measurements,
it's basically zero.
Keep in mind, tracing
metrics and census impact
are things that we use on all
services running at Google.
But just for info, you
can stay Google fast,
even while having thousands
of levels of microservices
instrumented with Census.
Not a problem.
BRANDON KVARDE: So
really no penalty
to doing that type
of instrumentation?
MORGAN MCLEAN: No.
In general, most of these--
unless you're doing
things like profiling
where it's constantly on--
in general, most
telemetry collection
has effectively no
impact on your app.
It consumes a little
bit of memory,
maybe like five megs of RAM,
but nothing in the critical path
for latency.
BRANDON KVARDE: Awesome.
All right, next question.
"What makes OpenCensus
different from, say, Grafana
or other monitoring tools?"
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yes.
Another question that
we get very often.
So it's really important
to keep in mind--
OpenCensus is just the
telemetry collection.
So it's just client
libraries that you
link to your application to send
telemetry to another back end.
One of those back
ends might be Grafana.
One of those back ends might
be Zipkin, or Prometheus,
or Stackdriver, or so on.
There are other projects,
like Zipkin or Prometheus,
for example, which offer the
full, end-to-end solution.
So Zipkin, for
example, has a back end
for processing, a fairly nice
UI that actually shows you
your traces that you captured--
Zipkin is a distributed
tracing system--
and it also has its
own instrumentation.
OpenCensus, I think, already
has much more breadth
of instrumentation than Zipkin's
built-in instrumentation
from its own project,
but it works with Zipkin.
And so if you want
to use Zipkin,
you can do that with OpenCensus.
It's a great way to do it.
It's what we recommend.
But yeah, the projects' very
scoped just on instrumentation.
BRANDON KVARDE: Got it.
Next question from the audience.
"How does OpenCensus compare to
agent based instrumentation?"
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yes.
This is actually a pretty
good technical question.
So OpenCensus, like, I think,
Zipkin and some other tracing
solutions, captures your
traces from a library
that you link to
your application.
This has some positives
and negatives.
So one of the big benefits
that I talked about
during our presentation
is that you can control it
through source control.
And so you can manage, through
source control, deployments.
You can do things like link
OpenCensus to your app,
change its version,
reconfigure it.
This is great if you're a
developer, because you're
already used to using source
control to make changes
to your app and redeploy them,
roll them back, and so on.
And so it's very native to you.
And you're already using your
languages, built-in package
management solution,
to get OpenCensus.
So Go, it's like, go get
OpenCensus, for example.
And so for developers, this
is really native to them.
The other benefit of
having a library that's
linked to your
application is you
can understand how it works.
All of the interfaces that
OpenCensus consumes or exposes
are visible to you.
And so when OpenCensus talks
to gRPC, you, as a developer,
can be pretty confident that
it's not doing some weird thing
that you don't understand,
and it's not poorly
impacting the
performance of your app.
You can also go and
change those interfaces
if you, for some
reason, need to.
It's also open source, which
means you can go and modify
OpenCensus if there's some
kind of critical issues that--
something crops up that other
people can't fix in time.
Agent-based instrumentation,
on the other hand,
which some vendors
use, is an executable
that you have running in
the background on Kubernetes
or on the VMs that
host your app.
One of the perceived benefits
of agent based instrumentation
is it's entirely automatic.
You download and
install this thing.
You run it, and it
just captures traces.
It captures metrics.
It keeps itself updated.
The challenge is
it's hard to version.
Agents are typically tied
to one of your VM images
that you build or
something like that.
Another challenge is
that if, for agents
that run on, say,
the JVM, for example,
they do things like
monkey patching
and a lot of weird
instrumentation tricks
to get data out of your app.
This generally works
relatively well.
But as a developer,
you don't always
have confidence that it's going
to do everything that you want.
Or you can never be too
sure of its interactions.
I'm not trying to bash
agent based instrumentation.
The automatic
benefits are tangible.
They're real.
But we've pretty
deliberately chosen
to do things in
process, so the library
that you link to your code.
We think it's better for
developers, because they
can better manage it.
And they can see
how things work.
Finally, it makes the
instrumentation process
a little easier.
For example, for gRPC,
we depend on some hooks
that the gRPC client libraries
expose to OpenCensus.
And we can version those and
be pretty confident they're not
going to change.
If you're doing agent
based instrumentation
and trying to do things
like monkey patch the JVM,
changes in the things
that you're instrumenting
can break you, even if
they're not technically
a breaking change.
And so we're pretty confident
that, in the long run,
this is a much better
approach for us.
BRANDON KVARDE: Got it.
Next question.
"What happens to
my data if there's
an interruption between
OpenCensus and my backends?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
Generally, if it's a
short interruption,
this isn't a problem.
So this is defined
in each exporter.
So I can speak for the ones that
we've written for Stackdriver,
for example.
But I think most vendors
have taken care of this
in a similar way that we have.
Typically, the export will do
a bit of buffering and retries.
If you have an interruption
for a large amount of time,
some of that data's
going to get dropped,
because you don't want your
exporter and OpenCensus
consuming a crazy amount of RAM.
But in general,
every vendor's going
to build really good logic
inside of their exporter
to deal with that.
We've talked to some
vendors about sharing it,
but it seems like most of
them have already built this,
because for their
own instrumentation,
they already had to
solve this problem.
BRANDON KVARDE: Got it.
MORGAN MCLEAN: So yeah.
BRANDON KVARDE: "What
additional telemetry types
do you want to
support long-term?"
MORGAN MCLEAN: That is also
a really good question.
So OpenCensus, today,
does tracing and metrics,
and another thing
that we call tags
that you can use to
link traces and metrics.
But we have much grander
ambitions long-term.
So one thing that we're
discussing right now
with our partners is support
for logging and exceptions.
This is less of a clear-cut
thing for us to do,
which is why we're spending the
time discussing it as a group.
For traces and
metric collection,
when we started development
of OpenCensus two years ago,
there wasn't a lot of prior art.
There were certainly a few
other products in this field,
but they either started roughly
around the same time as us--
whether that's Prometheus
or OpenTracing and others--
or they didn't suit
some of our needs.
But if you look
back before that,
there really wasn't
anything on the market.
And so it was a
relatively clear decision
to go and develop
things on our own.
When we look at
things like logging,
there are frameworks,
like for Java, like Log4j,
and the native Java logging
framework, and tons of others.
And so what we're
debating now is
whether we want to just
integrate with those--
and to be clear,
we're already doing
some of that work, where if
you have OpenCensus on Java,
we automatically add
trace IDs to your logs
so you can do
those correlations.
But what we're
really debating is
whether we want to do native
logging in OpenCensus.
So there'd be like
an OpenCensus log API
that you could
use to write logs,
just like we wrote metrics
and traces in that demo.
That's something we're
trying to figure out.
So there's discussions within
Google and certainly with us
and with partners like Microsoft
and others about how we
actually want to approach this.
In particular, we talked
about client applications.
So we think there's some pretty
big benefits to providing
a logging and errors API for iOS
and Android and other clients,
because there's not a lot
of other equivalents there.
Whether we want to do
that on the back end
is still under debate.
I suspect we will
do it at the end.
BRANDON KVARDE: OK.
Looks like we have time
for one last question.
"What's the history of
the name OpenCensus?"
MORGAN MCLEAN: That's funny.
In other presentations
I've done,
like at GCP Next
and other places,
I show OpenCensus
in the ecosystem,
and I show how Google
open-sourced Stubby is gRPC,
and Borg became Kubernetes,
and all these open source
projects from Google that
are these cool names.
Then I show Census became
OpenCensus because, clearly,
we're not the most creative.
The name, of course,
stems from Census,
which is effectively the same
thing used inside of Google.
So as I mentioned,
it's our library
to automatically collect
traces and metrics
and host our Borg status pages,
the Z-pages inside of Google.
How Census got its name is
not entirely clear to me.
It long predates
my time at Google.
I suspect it's
because a census is
when you have a survey
of many, many entrants
or many, many participants.
And given the number of
machines and processes
we have running at Google, it
seems somewhat appropriate.
And when we wanted
to open source it,
the team chose that they
wanted to call it OpenCensus.
BRANDON KVARDE: Very creative.
MORGAN MCLEAN: So not the
most exciting of stories,
but that's how the
project got its name.
BRANDON KVARDE: All right.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
BRANDON KVARDE:
Well thanks, Morgan,
for answering those questions.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
You're most welcome.
BRANDON KVARDE: Thank you,
everybody, for tuning in today.
Stay tuned for the
next session-- stream
processing with Cloud data
flow, SDKs, and architectures.
Thank you.